around the 22nd mark we can see the
carriage that is just sort of flying in
midair on its own now i suppose this
could be some sort of enchantment but i
think the most likely possibility here
is that it is indeed being pulled by
thestrals we know if you haven't
experienced death then you can't see
thestral so it could make sense that in
the beginning of the game maybe our
character hasn't experienced or seen
death yet so they don't see thestrals as
a result then we're gonna skip ahead a
little bit here to around 49 seconds and
i'm just gonna let it play and here
you're gonna see the changing staircases
now this again not a specific spell but
instead it is the enchantments of
hogwarts itself right there around the
55 second mark you see the book float
over to the character who grabs it out
of thin air now this does indeed look
like a cut scene of some sort but it
could mean that ossio is confirmed to be
in the game ossio accio axio however you
want to say it i prefer osseo there was
actually a scholastic pronunciation
guide years before they even thought
about making the movies and on there
they said osseo so that's how i always
pronounced it and the movies came out
and they decided to pronounce it accio
so whatever then we'll move forward a
bit more here to around 110 in the
trailer and you can see that's the
potion section followed by the herbology
and then back into potions where we see
this reaction right here
from the potion now i think it's just a
reaction of the potion but you can see
before that let's let's scroll back here
a little bit uh around 115 you can see
they point their wands at the potion and
the character here on the left side of
the screen you see how his wand is
starting to light up looks like purple
there and then the other characters you
see his briefly light up as well and
then we sort of get these purple sparks
and then blue comes out of the potion so
not really sure if that's a specific
spell or if the wand is somehow
interacting with the potion there i
can't think of any canon spell any spell
that we read about in the books if i'm
wrong let me know definitely i want to
hear from you guys down in the comments
of what you think about all these spells
as well from where i'm sitting i think
that one is probably more relating to
the potion rather than a specific spell
using the wand but i could totally be
wrong okay around 120 we have the moon
calves and then right after that we get
this scene here in what appears to be a
common room i think it's very possible
that this is the ravenclaw common room
but watch the character sitting in the
chair on our left i'm going to go back
and play it again here for you so
there's the moon cavs and let's let this
play one more time watch that right
there it's like he looks up and you can
see a little bit of pink come off the
wand i'm wondering if this is some sort
of vanish spell it almost looks like
he's trying to make something disappear
but then even after he does it there is
still you can see some kind of residual
sort of this glint of the light right
here i'm not really sure what that spell
is exactly let's look at it one more
time here
yeah i i think indeed it it it is
possible that it is vanishing there
immediately after this scene we get
another spell right here we see the
character cast it and then we see the
mirror transform into what looks like
some sort of spell casting dummy so
let's watch it one more time here
there's the spell cast and then you can
see the mirror transform so i think that
is just some sort of transfiguration
spell i don't know if there's a specific
spell we can point to i'm honestly super
excited about how they could use
transfiguration in the game it's
something that none of the other video
games i mean they've explored it a
little bit but i think hogwarts legacy
could go much much deeper and you could
see some really awesome things done with
transfiguration spells
then we're gonna let it play and it's
gonna go right into the scene around 128
129 when you have the flying hippogriffs
of course no specific spells here but
again you do have magical creatures and
the fact that we'll get to ride them
pretty much confirmed with this scene
right here then we're gonna get a shot
of the and fury here as well as the
dementors which makes me think hey if
you're gonna have dementors you gotta
have expecto patronum in there right
right okay now we have this scene right
here at 134 with the charging grab horn
now interesting fact about grab horn is
their hides are apparently stronger than
a dragon so this character right here
clearly not aware of that you're gonna
see him cast this red spell and if we
look at this in slow motion let's go
back here all right so here he goes you
see him getting ready to cast there goes
the cast and it's red it looks like it
bounces off the skull of the crap horn
my guess would be it's probably a
stunning spell we know that stupefy is
red and i i just i'm mostly intrigued in
this one about it bouncing off let's
watch it one more time here right there
yeah i think that is definitely bouncing
off the skull if you want to go and stop
it for yourself watch the official
trailer and try and stop it around let's
see here let's let it play again 134
yeah it's right as it goes to 135.
so i've got it stopped right there and
you can see yeah i definitely think the
spell hits and then just sort of shoots
ricochets right off the skull of the
grab horn which if so
is pretty cool obviously you'd love to
see that attention to detail there
around 153 we have this scene here that
starts with the troll and you're gonna
see the troll attempt to strike the
student right there so he ducks out of
the way and then he's gonna go in for
another one right here
and i think the spell that we see here
is protego it looks like a shield right
there you can see the blue sort of
shatter here it is one more time right
there the flash of blue and then see if
i can pause it right there for you you
see the character he's got his arms kind
of stretched out and he does appear to
be unscathed so i think he did indeed
block that right there all right not too
much further around the two-minute mark
we have the character here with the
animal bone mask you guys know we think
that could be tied to the main story of
the game and then in the very next bit
of the trailer we have this right here a
character doing battle against the
character with the animal bone so again
i'm gonna let it play slow here you can
see that character sort of swing up and
you get kind of this bluish purple light
off the wand and then the character with
the animal bones spinning in midair and
then watch the character the camera
shifts right here the character on the
left now they're going to slam their one
back down we get another flash of the
blue light as the character with the
animal bone mask smashes to the ground
now you might think maybe this is
something like wingardium leviosa
however when guardium leviosa there is
no light associated with it it is
considered a charm and if you remember
in the movies whenever when guardium
leviosa is cast the object just sort of
floats there in midair of course it can
be manipulated by the wizard but there
is no visual spell effect with it other
than the object moving in mid-air this
here is clearly something much different
another one that occurred to me is
possibly alarte ascindare which is what
gilderoy lockhart uses in harry potter
in the chamber of secrets this is a
charm that does require the brandishing
of the hand which all of that fits with
what we see in the trailer however the
lighting effect for this one is
supposedly red which is what's making me
second guess that one a little bit also
that second part there when when she
slams him back down i'm not sure if that
is a separate spell or if it's all part
of the same spell there's also ascendia
which this one does have a blue lighting
effect with it however its effect is
that it lifts the caster so if this was
ascendio being cast here then we should
expect to see the character on the left
actually rocketing up into the air
instead of the character on the right
you know the more that i think about
this one i think the second part is
definitely going to be descendo which is
blue i'm gonna read this quote from the
harry potter wiki here this is when
crabb tries to kill ron with descendo
quote with a whip-like movement crab
pointed his wand at the 50-foot mountain
of old furniture of broken trunks of old
books and robes and unidentifiable junk
and shouted
descendo the wall began to totter then
crumbled into the aisle next door where
ron stood so the effect here is that it
lowers the target so i think it could
just as easily be cast on an actual
person as opposed to an object so those
are my best guesses on that one
definitely let me know what you think
not too much further from that we have
the scene with the spiders i'm just
gonna go ahead and let it stay in slow
motion here there's the scene with the
crazy dragon look over there on the
right you can see those guys trying to
cast something all right if you want to
skip ahead you go to 205 for this one
this is where we get a red spell being
cast at charging spiders right there you
see it connect with the spider flip him
over on his back now my first thought
here was irania exume which is the spell
that harry uses in the chamber of
secrets movie however this one is a blue
light and there we can very clearly see
that it is red instead so for me i would
have to go back to stupefy on that one i
think that is the most likely option
there then here at 206 we get our look
at what could be some sort of duel
clearly a student here on the right
casting yet again another red spell most
likely stupefy at another man in a skull
mask don't know if it's the same guy in
the skull mask or a completely different
person in the skull mask but we can see
him almost absorb that red spell right
there at 206 look how he just completely
blocks it right there and then
immediately fires back one
two
and then a third spell so he blocks one
and then fires off three in rapid
succession i'm gonna back up here and
show you guys this right here at 207.
you can see that our character what i'm
assuming is our character over here on
the right they block the spell in return
as well so character on the right fires
the red spell guidance skull mask blocks
it fires it back and then our character
blocks it i think this is a good look
maybe the best look that we've seen so
far into what wizard v wizard spell
casting could look like in hogwarts
legacy this one here almost certainly
has to be protego on the hp wikipertego
is quoted as a charm that protects the
caster with an invisible shield that
reflects spells and blocks physical
entities so this would mean that not
only can it be used to block spells like
we see here it can also be used to block
physical objects like we saw back with
the troll and then finally the last
little spell we see is going to come at
that's right look at our character's
wand right here at the bottom of course
lumos is going to be in there you know
lumos is going to be in the game i hope
you guys enjoy this video definitely let
me know what you think about all these
spells tell me where i'm right tell me
where i'm wrong and as always thank you
so much for watching i'll talk to you
again soon